hello everyone i would like to welcome
you to today's webinar on rapid
evidence-based reporting of oncology ngs
tests at scale
which will be presented by dr piata
litzenberger and dr cheryl elkin
my name is marianne i'm the global
campaign manager for kyogen digital
insights and i'll be the host and
moderator for today
i'd like to introduce our speakers for
today
dr biata litzenberger and dr cheryl
elkin
iata is the global product director of
oncology for clinical decision support
software and interpretation services at
kyogen
prior to joining the kyogen team dr
litzenberger led clinical decision
support and the interpretation of
patient cases for several next
generation sequencing protocols at the
md anderson cancer center
in this role dr litzenberger was
responsible for providing alteration
interpretation drug and clinical trial
options to clinicians
cheryl is the chief scientific officer
at nf1 a hygiene company
an early member of the nf1 team dr elkin
has led the interpretation of thousands
of patient cases
establishing a rigorous process for the
analysis of scientific and clinical
evidence
and presentation of molecular and
clinical evidence to physicians to help
guide their therapeutic decisions
dr elkin has taken a lead role in the
development of the nf1 clinical
interpretation methodology to support
clinicians in identifying therapeutic
strategies specific to each patient
so again thank you for joining us today
and i will now hand the presentation
over to biata and cheryl
thank you so much for the introduction
skyrim digital insights offers a variety
of products and services to meet your
needs to call
call and interpret variants from ngs
essays
so let's focus here only on the tertiary
analysis solution
for molecular diagnostic labs performing
variant interpretation and reporting
in-house
pci interpret is a clinical decision
support software
that can be integrated in your existing
workflows and enables fast turnaround
times
high confidence reporting
and test menu expansion for oncology and
heritary diseases
now qci precision insights is a
professional clinical interpretation
service
that translates molecular data specific
to each patient into clinical insights
and therapeutic options
keys acquisition insights is focused on
interpreting tumor profiles
powered by a world-class team of
molecular biologists biologists and
oncologists
pci precision insights delivers expert
assembled reports
with detailed assessments of variants
written summaries of evidence with
references
treatments and geographically matched
clinical trials
the professional interpretation service
allows labs to scale
without extra stuffing and reduces the
test turnaround time by about 85 to 90
percent
now
all our tertiary products can be
customized towards your needs and help
you to scale
using
api integration workflow customization
and automation lymph integration and
variant filtering optimization
our
professional services also
develop report templates that allow you
to differentiate yourself for brand
recognition
competing to offer a comprehensive
genomic profiling service for tumor
samples is challenging especially as
panels increase in size and complexity
that means that we are more than ever
challenged to classify even more
variants
at the same time oncology drug
development advances and an increasing
number of treatment decisions require
evidence
and options beyond the current
guidelines which need to be guided by
the appropriate level of clinical
evidence from the literature
the expectations for thoroughness of
clinical reports are high
which requires a more than ever
comprehensive variant and
disease-specific research
and of course all this increased effort
needs to be done while maintaining rapid
turnaround times and achieving high
accuracy
therefore there is a need to reduce the
time-consuming task of researching and
writing variant and disease-specific
evidence summaries
in addition there's also need to be
confident in the accuracy
of the variant
classification by consulting an expert
second opinion
and to create an accurate content-rich
report ready to be sent to oncologists
we created qci interpret one
by combining the flexible and
automatable pci software powered by
superior structured content in the kaiju
knowledge base
with the trusted interpretation service
of nf1 a world leading provider of
chromatic variant interpretation
now qci interpret one allows lab to
confidently interpret variance
with disease-specific oncologist
reviewed content
as well as access an expert segment
opinion for increased confidence in
accurate varying classification
keysight interpret 1 allows labs to meet
their turnaround times without the
time-consuming step of researching and
writing variant and disease specific
evidence summaries
and with easy editorial control over the
report content and layout you can
deliver professional reports directly to
physicians to help inform clinical
decision making
now
the oncologist ready reports provide a
comprehensive overview of the patient's
molecular profile
expert
variant and disease specific summaries
are provided for biologically and
clinically relevant variants
the first page of the report not only
provides an overview of potentially
relevant treatments but also provides a
note
to the oncologist of any interaction
meaning if co-occurring mutations may
impact prognostic diagnostic relevance
or may affect therapeutic outcomes
oncologists will also receive a note if
guideline information is available which
then they can review on a subsequent
page of the report
so at a high level how do you generate
those comprehensive reports using
keysight interpret one
so data files are uploaded and
contextualized minimally
with a patient's disease type to allow
for accurate display of disease-specific
content
in the first step variants are
prioritized
based on the most clinically relevant
variant
in the subsequent step you can classify
the variance
and report trust treatment and trials
the last step the report building step
allows you to re retrieve ready to use
bearing industries specific summaries
without the time-consuming step of
writing those for yourself
in addition our experts provide a second
opinion on the varying classification to
increase the confidence and the accuracy
of your classification
and then the final reports can be
generated in form of a pdf
or can be downloaded and integrated in
the links using xml
gc interpret one is therefore powered by
the aggregated knowledge from the kyogen
knowledge base
combined with a trusted professional
interpretation service from nf1 which
has been a kaiju company now for over a
year
now pci interpret one is built on a
flexible platform
which allows you to access many turnkey
workflows for a variety of commercial
and off commercial of the shelf panels
but also allows you to configure the
workflows according to your needs
in addition you have the flexibility to
manually interact with the software in a
user interface
or partially or completely automate the
workflow to reduce the hands-on time and
therefore increase the turnaround time
his entrepreneur 1 takes advantage of
more than 20 years of expert curation of
genomic and cancer-related literature
aggregated in the kaiju knowledge base
combined with more than 10 years of
accumulated knowledge in providing
professional interpretation services for
somatic varying interpretations
and thus empowers your lab with the
world's largest manually curated
knowledge of biological and clinical
variant and disease-specific information
now i want to first focus on the kaiju
knowledge base before uh dr cho alken
will take over and
discuss and introduce the curation and
interpretation service
so
what differentiates the kaiju knowledge
base from other databases
it basically transforms unstructured
data from the literature into machine
readable units
to allow computing of content for every
patient case
the knowledge-based structure allows us
to aggregate manually curated scientific
literature and professional guidelines
and model the data with semantic
consistency
the knowledge base allows us to capture
biological phenotypic therapeutic and
outcome data for subsequent
transformation into clinically relevant
information for each patient case
so how does kaizen transform
unstructured data into computable units
so this is accomplished to a unique
knowledge-based model and curation
process
the expert curators which are phd and md
levels
read the scientific literature including
the figures tables supplementary
information and use rigid curation
protocols and curation tools to add each
relationship such as an alteration
clinical effect drug and disease
association
into a structured format in the
knowledge base
now we can use these relationships and
units to compute the pathogenicity and
actionability for each variant
and return varying and disease-specific
information for each case
in addition we use natural language
generation processing
to return in a human readable sentence
the essence of an experiment for example
a functional study or a clinical trial
result from a paper
now how often is the data in the kaiju
knowledge base updated
to ensure an up-to-date knowledge base
the content is updated mostly on a
weekly basis which allows us to cope
with the increasing number of variants
specific literature
the changing information from labels
trials guidelines and an increasing
accumulation of expertly written
molecular function summaries
powered by nf1 and changing disease
relationships
keta interpret 1 displays information
from a variety set of
different databases those databases
allow you to rapidly assess the
frequency of this alteration of
individuals from the general population
as well as understand the somatic
frequency of this alteration and context
of this diagnosis
pci interpret one allows you to retrieve
or review records
for that exact variant from other
laboratories
and thus saving you time of doing the
individual queries manually
to know
um q scientific one supports two
gene models that's the rastic gene model
and ensemble gene model
now
why do i spend so much time providing
insights into the kaiser knowledge base
it's because the machine readable data
allows computing of content for each
patient case
so what does that mean for variant
interpretation
first key centripetal one can instantly
prioritize clinically relevant variants
from any assay
second
future interpret one is able to provide
for every variant
across a whole genome in any cancer type
the computed hcmg and amp based
classification
uh the molecular function incidence and
disease
if hereditary clinical cases are
available
treatments there and disease specific
outcome studies and open and recruiting
clinical trials
so let's dive into the qci interpret one
application
so how is this information from the
kaiju knowledge base displayed in qsa
interpret one
this is
the
variant list of an ngs result of a
breast calcinoma patient sample
each row represents an alteration
detected in the tumor tissue
the different colors such as red pink or
gray display the qci computed
pathogenicity of an alteration
and in the bottom
center
indicates the qci computed actionability
classification
the smaller batches to the right
such as the s or r
provide an initial clue what information
is available for this variant
for example a barrier is sensitive or
resistant to therapy
this view basically provides a broad
overview of the patient's molecular
profiles and allows flexible filtering
to prioritize the alterations that would
require a deeper review
now the variant list page allows you to
also identify variants that have been
previously observed by experts from nf1
where there is an indication of an
e icon on the tile of a variant
nf1 has previously observed and expertly
interfered interpreted over 170 000
variants
and using the combined knowledge from
the kaiju knowledge base
and the expert
allows you to confidently distinguish
variants of uncertain significance from
those that may have clinical relevance
so
just as an example clicking on the
functional
icon
opens the reported function impact
section which provides you with an
expertly written
summary of the molecular function
backed up with references
in addition
you have access to the curated
references from the kaiju knowledge base
and computed biochemical impacts from
various prediction tools
and the combined knowledge allows you to
confidently interpret the functional
impact and relevance of this mutation
now in a different example alternatively
the combined knowledge allows you to
confidently distinguish variants of
uncertain significance
from those that may have clinical
relevance
so in this example here pci interpret
one does not display
literature evidence from the cardio
knowledge base about this variant
now on top of that nf1 experts did a
targeted curation of this variant and
specifically researched the literature
and database sources and determined
unknown impact
now
for each variant that is detected in the
patient's profile qci interpret one
provides a one-stop shop organized in
several expandable session section for
you to review detailed information about
the alteration and context of the user
submitted phenotype
in interest of time i'm not able to dive
into the details of each section but i
want to highlight a few important
sections
the laboratory observations section is a
quick and transparent way to review and
track the history of the variant
classification across several different
phenotypes
and the effect on protein section allows
you to quickly understand the location
of the mutation energy and if it falls
into
an important domain highlighted here in
yellow
it also allows you to see if the variant
falls into a region where typically
pathogenic mutations are observed
this view also provides an idea if
mostly gain of function
mutations or loss of function mutations
are observed in this gene
further highlighted
in this red box
are the pic3ca variants found in this
patient
in this case you can see that this
patient contains a thick swiss area
double mutation
the observation of patient has a single
or double mutation energy may be of
political relevance as double mutations
can lead to an increased or decreased
drug sensitivity
now q2 interpret one provides in the
varying details section front and center
an assessment section
which displays the computed
applicability and pathogenicity criteria
the actuality is based on amp guidelines
the pathogenicity is based on the acmg
guidelines
so here i want to focus on the
actionability for this variant
all clears
that are applicable will be shown to
transparently indicate the actuality
options for this alteration
for each tier the underlying clinical
evidence can be viewed which provides
transparency in the sources that support
each tier
one thing to note is that
the user still has full control of
adjusting the actionability criteria by
removing or adding a criterion
or just manually adjusting the final
assessment of the alteration
in this section the user has the ability
to report out the pathogenicity and
actionability for each alteration
now
within the treatment section of the
variant details page qcr interpret 1
shows pre-selective treatments for the
draft report which is of course
adjustable
for each drug response a level of
evidence is provided in context of the
disease and for transparency references
are provided
now the last step is the report building
step that allows you to generate
comprehensive reports in minutes
without the time consuming step to write
interpretive comments by yourself
in the review and report page
pre-science weapon 1 displays all the
variants that should be reported
and also indicates
in the expert interpretation column
which variants will receive varying
entities specific interpretation
and this is done with a simple click on
submit for expert interpretation
now in this moment i'm handing handling
over to my colleague dr alkin
who will describe in depth the expert
interpretation component of qci
interpret one
thank you dr litzenberger for your
excellent presentation and kind
introduction
the expert interpretation component of
qci interpret one is driven by qci
precision insights the former n of one
qci precision insights provides human
analysis on top of the computed variant
classifications provided by qci
interpret
allowing for detailed interpretation of
gray areas in complex scientific
situations
precision insights also triages and
summarizes content for lab director
review to assist in report writing
helping to further shorten turnaround
times
so who is n of one
n of one was founded in 2008 and we have
grown and evolved with the field of
precision medicine
back at the beginning we work directly
with physicians and their patients to
help them to identify the most
appropriate molecular tests for their
tumors get the tests done and then
explain the results
through the process of working with
individual patients and physicians nf1
established a knowledge base of
biomarkers genes and variants in the
context of different cancer types linked
with drugs that had emerging or
established evidence that they could
target those biomarkers
in 2012 we began working with large
hospital systems and commercial
laboratories
taking in the results of patient
molecular tests and providing reports
and by 2016 we had partnered with over
30 clinical laboratories to provide
clinical interpretation
in 2019 we joined kyogen having
generated reports for over 100 000
patient cases with a deep knowledge base
covering over eighteen hundred genes and
over one hundred thousand unique
variants these numbers continue to grow
every day as we have now processed over
two hundred thousand cases
in 2020 our professional interpretation
service
has expanded clinical variant
interpretation services to europe and
have now integrated with qci interpret
to create qci interpret one an
end-to-end clinical interpretation
product that takes the user from vcf to
final report
qci interpret one accesses the
accumulated knowledge of n of one which
has assembled over 12 years of manual
expert interpret expert clinical
interpretation by full-time dedicated
phd scientists
the scientists undergo a rigorous
training process including defined
practices for analysis and
interpretation of scientific studies
qci interpret 1 provides report-ready
variant and disease-specific
interpretation summaries on all kinds of
biomarkers including snvs indels fusions
and cnvs as well as support from
microsatellite instability and tumor
mutation burden
the variants are described specifically
in terms of their molecular impact and
are classified according to the amp
guidelines published in 2017
variant and disease-specific clinical
evidence
covering potential therapeutic options
as well as prognostic and diagnostic
significance where applicable is
reviewed and approved by a team of
practicing medical oncologists this team
of oncologists practices across oncology
subspecialties and have been
collaborating with the nf1 team for many
years
the qci interpret 1 interpretation also
includes summaries of disease and
gene-specific relevant treatment
guidelines as well as analysis of
multivariant interactions
the
between variants in the same gene or
between different genes
these interactions are selected based on
the level of evidence and pre-curated
based on the literature and detection
and analysis of the interactions can be
fully automated and reported
as of today over two hundred thousand
cases have been interpreted with over
one hundred seventy thousand unique
somatic variants across over 1 000 genes
and 1 000 cancer subtypes
the expert written interpretation
summaries within qci interpret 1 are
configurable the information is highly
structured and users can configure which
sections they would like to view within
the user interface and in the final
report we have pre-configured three
options a complete option which contains
the deepest and richest information a
concise option which contains only the
highest level summary information and an
intermediate version
the configurations are also flexible in
the event that the pre-configured
options do not meet a user's needs
so how does this information appear in
the user interface
when biata left off on the review and
report page she had clicked the submit
for expert interpretation button
typically within a few minutes this page
is then populated with the variant and
disease specific expert interpretations
in the overall interpretation section
shown here
you will see information that applies to
the case as a whole summaries of any
applicable treatment guidelines and
reference descriptions of any variant
interactions
below
you will see the list of reportable
variants and the expert interpretation
column has now been populated
with colored squares with green
indicating the experts agreed with qci
and the yellow indicating a disagreement
if you click on the triangle next to the
gene you can open open the expert
interpretations
here we have opened the pic3ca variant
and you can see we are showing an
example of the rich content at the
deepest level of detail
the content is highly standardized and
structured and always in the same order
so that the user always knows where to
look for a given piece of information
for example if they want to know if the
variant is associated with sensitivity
to any drugs
they would look down to the drug
sensitivity section
if they wanted to know the specific
molecular impact of the mutation on the
gene
they would look up to the molecular
function section
sections for diagnostic and prognostic
significance are also included as you
can see here but they are seldom
populated in solid tumor cases as the
prognostic and diagnostic impact of
molecular alterations is more well
studied in heme and neural oncology
still all sections are included so that
the user always knows where to look
additionally every sec sentence is
referenced so that if a user does want
to review the primary evidence it is
provided the interpretation is fully
transparent to the evidence that was
used to build it
the content from the expert
interpretation can be used as a second
set of eyes to help verify and give
confidence in the variant classification
and interpretations
for example the variant shown here is a
jack 3 truncation that was computed as a
tier 3
unknown significance variant
in this case the expert interpretation
is in agreement with the qci computed
classification the jack 3 truncation is
likely deleterious to the protein but
because activation of jack 3 has been
implicated in cancer the relevance to
cancer of a jack 3 truncation is unknown
the expert interpretation in this case
supports the computed classification
i would also like to point out the edit
button here the users have editorial
control to refine the content for the
report in the event that they would like
to add or remove a piece of information
change wording or otherwise revise the
content
these changes can be saved and will be
easily accessible for future cases
after the lab director has reviewed all
the variants that they wish to review
and made any desired changes to content
or classification
they are ready to preview and sign out
the report
the buttons at the top of this page
allow flexibility
to assign reports within different users
and different roles within an
organization so that if a variant
scientist is working on a case for
example they can assign it to another
scientist or to a lab director for sign
out the user can also click the preview
report button to generate a pdf report
and here is an example of the draft
report the version you see here is the
qci interpret one report template but it
can be customized for individual
laboratories incorporating logos and
making other changes
additionally the content can be exported
via xml and uploaded into a laboratory's
own report template or lims
allowing the laboratory ultimate
flexibility to build its own report and
establish a brand
at the top of the report you see an
overall comment which can be composed in
the user interface if no overall comment
is supplied this section is not included
in the draft report
the variants are presented on the
summary page according to the guidance
in the amp guidelines
tier 1 contains variants of strong
clinical significance variants that are
associated with therapies approved
within the specific indication
also shown here are therapies with
evidence of resistance as well as
clinical trials
tier two contains variants of potential
clinical significance
and also shown on this page are variants
of biological significance clearly
pathogenic variants and likely drivers
of cancer but with no available targeted
therapies or trials and without
significant prognostic or diagnostic
relevance
the front page also has pointers that
inform the user to information about
interactions and guidelines as well as a
table of contents
getting into the body of the report
there is a guideline section that
appears when applicable this contains a
summary of disease specific guidelines
that are relevant to the detected
biomarkers in this case erb2 and pic3ca
in breast cancer
the interaction section summarize
interactions summarizes interactions
between variants
as described earlier
the interactions are researched by our
team of phd scientists and reviewed and
confirmed by oncologists
they must reach a defined level of
evidence for inclusion
interactions can affect drug sensitivity
and resistance they can also modulate
the prognostic implications and
combinatorial variants can be used to
inform diagnosis
in this case there is some conflicting
evidence pic3ca and herbi2 alterations
do not often co-occur
and pic3ca mutation may be associated
with resistance to rb2 targeted therapy
but the evidence is unclear
the herbi2 targeted therapies are still
included in the report the information
here is provided so that the physician
is aware of a potential cause of
resistance that they may observe
treatment options are shown on this page
as well users have the options to review
and select from the proposed therapies
directly or to automatically report
therapies using a predefined reporting
policy as described earlier by dr
litzenberger
the text that's shown here in the report
describes the information that is
contained on the drug label
clinical trials can also be manually or
automatically selected and are shown
here organized by the phase of the
clinical trial
the next page shows the detailed
clinical interpretation that has been
provided through the expert
interpretation service
in this slide we are again showing the
most detailed rich information possible
as i mentioned earlier the amount of
content displayed is configurable the
more concise content is supported by the
rich content seen here you always know
that even if you are only reading the
concise content the detailed research
has been done by the phd's on the nf1
team
the information is highly structured and
presented in increasing levels of detail
the information shown first at the top
is a high level summary
what kind of variant is this an
activating mutation
what is the role of variance in this
gene in cancer are there any therapies
available to target this gene
the disease summary
gives the most important gene about this
gene in this disease
the next sections get into the
biological relevance of the alteration
the molecular function section describes
the impact of this specific variant on
the protein along with all the
supporting references what does this
variant do is it activating is it
inactivating what is the evidence are
there biochemical studies demonstrating
kinase activation or does this mutation
lead to transformation of cancer cells
or tumors in mice
next what is the incidence of
alterations in this gene in this cancer
type
and finally role in disease what role
does this gene play in the development
of cancer in general or in this cancer
type specifically
the next sections describe the clinical
relevance of the alteration is there
diagnostic or prognostic significance
for this mutation
does the mutation predict sensitivity to
any drugs resistance to any drugs
and then finally the most detailed
information the clinical evidence
section
this section provides detailed data to
support the more summary level
information that precedes it the
information summarizes data from
individual clinical trials it is
specific to the cancer type and
organized by the phase of the
information from which the data is
thrived or the phase of the clinical
trial from which the data is derived
this information tends to be most often
used by academic laboratories and
molecular tumor boards it allows them to
see the specifics of the data without
needing to take the time to do the
research identify and read the papers
the information shown
is we can we will show the highest level
information for any given drug or any
given therapeutic approach so that if a
phase 3 study is shown in summary here
the same drug information
would not be shown from an earlier
clinical trial unless it's in a
different
clinical context or a different drug
combination
and therefore
limiting the extent of this very deep
and detailed data
this is an example of a concise version
of the report as explained earlier the
content sections included are flexible
but this is one example of the high
level information that might be most
critical without including all of the
supporting details which again
the
scientific team has done the research to
make the summary conclusions
to summarize qci interpret one brings
together the knowledge and expertise
from the kaijan knowledge base and over
a decade of nf1 expert interpretation to
create an end-to-end solution that is
unparalleled in the field
qci interpret one combines flexible
software with state-of-the-art
interpretation
that allows users to confidently
interpret variants using the power of
computed classifications and a second
set of expertise
qci interpret one helps laboratories to
accelerate turnaround time by providing
expert curated oncologist reviewed
written summaries that can be directly
added to a report or edited to reflect
the preference of the laboratory
in the end the user has full editorial
control over the classifications content
drugs and clinical trials as well as the
design of the report that can be
configured to fit the needs and brand of
the lab all of which will help a
laboratory to differentiate and succeed
in the market
and with that we thank you for your
attention
if you would like to request a demo
please go to the displayed website or
google qci interpret one to access the
website for requesting a demo
and with that we would be happy to take
any questions that you may have thank
you very much
thank you cheryl and biata for that
presentation
so
now we're going to have some time to go
over any questions that you have
moving into the questions
the first one is you talked about the
update frequency of the kyogen knowledge
base
how do you update the interpretive
comments
hi so i'd be happy to take that question
the interpretive comments um the expert
interpretation are coming from
the nf1 team
and
that is a live knowledge base that's
being updated on a regular basis um
everything in the knowledge base has a
um an expiration date so to speak so
things are updated
at least annually but every different
piece of information has its own amount
of time that it's allowed to expire so
we're making sure that we're
that we're reviewing the information
regularly and pre-loading new
information
additionally
new drug approvals are incorporated
within a business day
and
um
uh
updates to guidelines are also
incorporated within one to two business
days
okay thank you cheryl
our next question is
how are the oncologists involved in the
process of validating the clinical
evidence in the interpretation summaries
sure so i can take that one as well we
have a team of nine oncologists
that um have been working with us for
many years they
span the clinical subspecialties you
know from heme to neural oncology and
and multiple different types of solid
tumor focuses including thoracic and
breast
gi
and they regularly review the
annotations that our scientists
are
um bringing into the knowledge base so
any uh root uh piece of information
that's summarizing the literature
that has to do with anything clinically
related so a clinical impact of a of an
alteration or
a review of a clinical trial
that would be
um submitted to our oncologist for
review and we've developed a very
efficient system to to alert them that
there's something for them to review and
they're reviewing within our system on a
daily basis they're all practicing
oncologists most of them also have
research active research programs
and they also consult with us on
associations of drugs and clinical
trials with particular biomarkers
and other scientific topics that
that we are looking for extra clinical
input
so they lend a real clinical eye to the
information that we're providing
okay thank you
we've um had a couple questions about
input files
so
what kind of variants can qci interpret
one process and interpret
and what file types can be
inputted into the informatic system
yeah i'm happy to comment on that um
so um casa interpret one is the um
tertiary analysis solution um so
if it goes straight into pc interface
one this standard format is the pcf
former um that follows the standard uh
four-point um you know x i would say um
formats um now there are outputs from
other pipelines secondary analysis
pipelines
that output several different formats um
one specifically i have in my mind is
the tsl500 platform they output several
different formats outside of the bcf
format and we're able to intake that as
well
um
now there are um
some uh platforms that um
do have very unconventional um output
files so we do have some methods that
allows us to upload the data via an xml
um
into the system or we do have in the
user interface also a way to upload um
this
in this case manually but with the xml
is an automated way
um
the other question was what are the
alteration types that are supported so
um
the um
the output size from a from a second
analysis typically gets into the copy
numbers diffusions and small variants
and so all of them are supported
we do support
anything that we can encode in
structural variant files
insertions the larger deletions uh
smaller deletions um
inversions and of course the copy
numbers as well
um
so the so there's all the structural
variants the small variants you know
smbs and delts
we do support other formats as well as
your quality of the um you can upload it
as well
into the into the into the pipeline we
we interpret that
um
so there is another question around if
we can incorporate too far so it depends
on like your
pipeline so
um we can't run the second analysis
pipeline and automatically upload into
our system as well so if you wish to use
a cost hue all the way to report report
that's possible as well
great thank you biata
okay
uh the next question that we have is how
long will it take for the professional
interpretation services
to provide me with the interpretive
comments
sure i can take that one as well so
we have two different
levels of service so the first one would
be the pre-curated version and that
would return expert comments within
just
a couple of minutes one to two minutes
usually
and that is drawing the information off
of our database you know based on over
over 200 000 curated cases and variants
so and pre-curated information as well
so whatever is currently present in the
knowledge base would be pulled in um to
the qci uh user interface um we also and
and in that case if there were a variant
that were novel that hadn't been covered
uh by the um the nf1 team
um then it would be returned as variant
not curated by n of one with the caveats
in appropriate places um but returning
gene and disease level content as
available
um we also have a curation service
option where
the team will curate every piece of
information for the report so every
novel variant um filling in information
on the the gene and disease level as
necessary doing any required updates and
that um
we we promise within up to three days um
but usually on average those are turned
around also within um on average about a
half day
okay thank you cheryl
next we have um
when you're showing the sample report
the slides were on a solid tumor sample
this qci interpret one process heme or
neuro-oncology samples
yes we do um the
both the the hydrogen knowledge base and
the um the nf1 team
expert interpretation knowledge base
both cover
um solid tumors heme
and
neural oncology as well and our oncology
experts span those
subspecialties as well so we have input
from clinical
hematologist oncologist and a
neurooncologist that weigh in again from
that clinical perspective
okay
i think we have one more question left
again if anyone does have any additional
questions please use the ask questions
panel on the left side of your screen to
submit them
so uh the last question that we have for
now is
does qci1 cover tmb msi fusions and cnv
yeah i think i commented on that before
um is that yes we do cover tmb msi
fusion and copy numbers um
so again depends on the upload files we
will display the information i want to
comment on one thing with just the
fusions um it is important to
take into consideration the fusion
breakpoint so we do display that
diffusion breakpoints um that is that
are encoded into in in your in your
files
um and despite that information then
when um
and at the same time so when when you're
con
consulting our experts for
interpretation and they take those break
points into consideration
for interpretation and that's that's
important to understand if um a kindness
domain is cut off or if certain
important functional domains are fused
together that create a potential
oncogenic fusion or
a potential um
kindness that fusion
for this important protein targeting
these particular regions for appropriate
direct or organization
okay great thank you biata
so that looks like we've reached the end
of our questions so
i'd like to thank our speakers for today
dr biata lutzenberger and dr cheryl
elkin
i also want to thank the audience for
attending for your attention and also
for submitting the questions
so this concludes today's session on
rapid evidence-based reporting of
oncology in gs test at scale
and we look forward to hosting you in a
future webinar so thank you everyone and
i hope you have a good rest of your day